in the heart of wagadugu a tribute to a
pan-african icon and a symbol of
strength and defiance burkina faso's
president thomas ankara was killed in a
coup 25 years ago long before elda kuama
was even born and yet his murder trial
is important and significant to her it
comes at a time of uncertainty following
monday's coup we need justice so we can
even believe in the in a possible future
this has been only few days
that we are in this
situation
you know we have no government let's say
that we have
no
institutional
laws that are stable now so we are just
asking ourselves
if we can just hope that what has been
started will continue so i think it
won't affect this is what i think
but i'm not sure
last monday as lawyers in tomah
sankara's murder trial were about to
give their closing statements the
hearing was abruptly adjourned it
happened after colonel damiba arrested
the president and took power in a coup
in a televised statement he said justice
will follow its course their trial is
now set to resume in the dock of the
accuses colonel damiba's former
commander gilbert gender he along exiled
former leader bless compare are accused
of being behind sankara's murder
everyone turns they want the truth but
actually they want their version of the
truth
and not the reality of what happened
shortly after kompari was ousted from
power in a popular uprising in 2014
diandere staged a coup
it's in this hotel in the wealthy
neighborhoods on the outskirts of
ragadugu that heads of states from the
west african block ecowas met with
general gender they held talks ended the
coup which led to his arrest this was
seen as a success for ecowas in
restoring democracy to this country
three coups in one year ekkowas is now
facing an institutional and regional
crisis
satirical cartoonist damian getz fears
the latest coup could delay sankara's
trial
about the death of sankara we all feel
like we know what actually happened
who did what and who was where
the question here is are we going to be
able to purge the current political
situation and bring justice so we can
move on
for people like kuama leaving the past
behind also means forging ahead into an
uncertain future nicholas hawk al
jazeera wagaduku